you
hi everyone is Jerry this is a group of
five puzzles and each of them it's white
to play and it's up to you to determine
the best continuation so go ahead pause
the video see we can find the best play
for white ok the solution to puzzle 1 is
to start out with Brooke h8 king takes
his forced and after pawn takes pawn
there's now no good solution to the
threat on the rook as well as mate on h1
black could try B takes a and white has
to be a little bit careful not to just
throw the King in the corner
since rook be one would be defending
against the maid on h1 and then black
would have time to meet the threat on
their rope
black would be winning but what would be
simple enough is to just take on a - a
check could be thrown in but after King
to a 1 yet again there is no good
solution to these two threats eh 1 white
is winning moving on to the second white
to play pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation ok solution
to puzzle - is to start out with the
quiet Queen to f6 which is setting up
something that is quite devastating
namely a queen sacrifice a double check
and then a mate how it would work
exactly well let's run with D take C
there's not really a great response for
black after this silent move Queen to f6
Queen h8 King takes here comes now the
double check Bishop and rook are
converging on the King followed up with
mate if the King tries to run after
Queen f6 this doesn't work either
take on h5 yet again this is game over
moving on to the third White's a play
pause the video see if you can find the
best play okay this is a checkmate in
five puzzle and it starts off with Queen
to d8 all these moves are very direct
all of them come with check the King
could play to h7 Queen the g8 would be
main pawn takes rook h6 King takes is
forced Queen
AJ the rook blocking is forced Queen
takes rook that's game over a good
puzzle for trying to calculate
accurately but having a close eye on
these direct moves these checking moves
might have led you to the correct
solution moving on to the fourth white
to play pause the video see if we can
find the best play ok the solution to
this one is not to play ripp to h4 right
away but rather rook to f6 and this move
is one that I think everybody should
think about first because it's
threatening made on H 7 h8 but it's
important to recognize the potential
defensive resources Black has if Rick h4
right away notice how there is a check
the queen is now there to defend but
rook to f6 keep in mind doesn't allow
the Queen to give check and it also
threatens a checkmate with rook to g6
let's just make a knight move here's the
check main threat of rook takes on g6
Queen takes on g6 and only then rook to
h4 and that would be mate there's not
really a great response for black after
rook to f6 taking the rook allows this
pond to now control g7 and mate will
come shortly on that Square and one
other try is to maybe allow this rook to
be defending along the second-ranked
to meet this type of threat where black
could be in a position to block however
after this East six move white doesn't
do this but rather comes over to h4 only
at this point only after first stopping
the Queen from potentially getting to
the g7 square play to h4 the Queen key
give a check she could also give another
check
but after Bishop to b1 black is now
forced to give up their queen with let's
say queen takes rook and white is of
course winning this
so it's important to see again the
defensive resource for black not rook to
h4 right away
keeping a close eye and what type of
response is black would have after your
your first move it's ripped to f6 to
begin okay moving on now to the fifth
and final white to play pause the video
see if we can find the best play ok the
solution to this one well it's a
checkmate in three and it starts off
with first Queen takes rook King takes
Queen rook check followed by mate with
the pun and I guess it might have been
very tempting I know when I first did
this I was looking into this move
because there would then be this double
check certainly these are the types of
variations you should be considering the
ones that are quite forceful and double
check it doesn't get too much more
forceful than that but there's not
really anything more after a king takes
pawn there but simply taking the rook
giving check on this back rank and then
mating with the pawn that's game over
and that's the solution to puzzle 5 so
that's all for this video let me know
how you did in the comment section below
and feel free to check out the chess
puzzles and chess
tips playlist that I'll include at the
end of this video if these sorts of
things are of interest to you that's all
for now take care bye
you